plus de 800 personnes ont été mobilisées
mais toujours aucune trace du petit
Emile l'enfant de 2 ans et demi a
disparu le 8 juillet au village du
Verney dans les Alpes-de-Haute-Provence
lundi soir Rémy Avon le procureur de la
République de Digne-les-Bains affirmait
que toutes les hypothèses restaient
d'actualité que savons-nous des
circonstances de la disparition des
milles ça me dit après-midi le garçonnet
jouait dans le jardin de ses
grands-parents au Vernet un village de
125 habitants coincé dans les montagnes
bientôt deux témoins la perçoivent dans
une rue descendante il est 17h15
l'enfant est seul c'est là que nous
perdons sa trace explique le procureur
il est 18h quand ses grands-parents
signalent sa disparition un important
dispositif est rapidement déployé
gendarmes pompiers voisins et volontaire
plus de 800 personnes au total se
relèvent pour mener des battues sur un
périmètre de 5 km autour du hameau le
préfet a salué un incroyable élan de
solidarité de la part des citoyens
mobilisés mais 48 heures plus tard pas
le moindre indice n'a été trouvé au bout
de 48 heures l'enfant aurait dû être
retrouvé dans ce périmètre mais on
n'arrête pas les recherches on ne perd
pas espoir les gendarmes ont même tenté
de diffuser par haut-parleur un message
enregistré par la mère des milles et
destinée à rassurer l'enfant au cas où
il serait caché mais sans succès s'il
est encore vivant et mille aurait passé
trois nuits dehors sans boire ni manger
dans des conditions de canicule dès ce
mardi le site est fermé à toute personne
étrangère du bourg à indiquer le préfet
de la région et un nouveau dispositif de
recherche plus ciblée et sélectif et
mise en place concrètement on arrête les
battues pour déployer des moyens
spécialisés à la recherche de traces et
d'indices les investigations se
poursuivent toutes les maisons du Vernet
hormis deux abandonné ont été fouillés
de nombreux habitants auditionnés à ce
stade aucun élément de caractérise une
infraction pénale susceptible d'être à
l'origine de cette disparition de son
côté le maire du Verney François Bali ne
croit pas à la piste d'un enlèvement
vous imaginez on est en Haute Provence
un petit village dans lequel il y a une
vingtaine de maisons on voit tout moi je
l'exclus on peut tout imaginer mais
c'est plus qu'un probable
[Musique]